[Musique]
je me souviens de la ryder cup qui
s'était déroulé aucun club en irlande
là c'était plus un moment d'émotion
moment où on fait darren clarke ta
meilleurs moments de sa vie il avait
perdu sa femme je crois au mois d'août
il avait joué à l'open britannique
également mois de juillet de façon à
pouvoir voir se pouvait rentrer dans les
points dans la ryder cup ils loupent
look est enfin bon plein de me plaindre
des choses notamment mais comme je le
disais le la perte de sa femme et gunnm
snam qui le prend dans ses capitaines ce
pic dans ses choix de capitaine est en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que darren
clarke
je pense poussé par sa femme de là haut
a gagné tous ses matches et notamment
les deux doubles sur lesquels ils
avaient joué le simple également et là
c'est toute l'émotion qui ressortit ben
c'est à dire que en fait on l'image qui
est très forte c'est à la fois mes
joueurs américains qui sont venus le
voir qu'ils ont en lacets et surtout moi
ce que j'ai adoré comme une image c'est
ian woosnam prenant dans ses bras darren
clarke donc est à peu près 30
centimètres d'écart entre les entrées
deux joueurs bien évidemment c'est un
moment émouvant parce que moments durs
pour clark mais de voir ces deux joueurs
ces deux champions en larmes sur ce gris
lamont voilà moi ça m'a réellement
retourner et je pense que la ryder
encore une fois c'est le seul événement
sur lequel on peut me golfique on peut
se retrouver à avoir des émotions
pareilles
[Musique]